[Music]
joining me now for reaction a host of
the Reuben report Dave Reuben Dave
you've got a very interesting
perspective on this you know we had
there are a lot of liberals out there a
lot of people who just don't want this
rally to happen there their content was
saying no you shouldn't get out here and
do this you shouldn't do those types of
things they were fine with the protests
and the riots but they're not okay with
the president doing this what's your
reaction to that well Jason I think you
know a little bit about my story I I was
a lefty and I still consider myself a
liberal in the good sense of it in that
I believe in individual rights and
limited government but of course we know
this is all of a media making event here
I mean look as the governor just laid
out they're gonna take people's
temperatures they're gonna give masks
there's gonna be Purell and hand
sanitizer and the rest of it if this was
a rally to take down a monument or to
smash things up or burn a target or the
rest of it the media would be completely
all in on it so this is just another one
of those things where the media picks
when we can have thousands of people
together and it's okay and that
apparently is when you're looting or
taking down monuments and when it's not
okay is when the president's going to
speak but I think most Americans
regardless of whether you're on the left
or on the right most Americans see the
world and they go hey if the choice is
anarchy and people running in the
streets and and burning down buildings
and Trump even if you have some aversion
to Trump if you're not say a hardcore
conservative well of course you're gonna
go with Trump I just love it like the
mayor of Los Angeles Garcetti he says oh
you know let's defund the police
department but he won't give up his own
security detail the City Council will go
ahead and keep their police officers
close to the VESA they can have
protection people that have money and
resources they're gonna go out and hire
their own protection they're gonna they
will continue to be safe and secure but
it's these these downtrodden communities
the ones that can't afford it those are
the people that are actually gonna
suffer more than anything else how does
a National Party win on an anti-police
platform well I don't think you can win
I mean that's the thing that's the irony
it's like where are the real Democrats
all they have to do is stand up for
basic law and order and yet they refused
to now you mentioned Eric Garcetti I'm
here in Los Angeles so he is my mayor
this is a guy who a week and a half ago
was on his knees in front of black lives
matter protesters but I can tell you
that the silver lining to what's
happening right now is the further that
these anti feh and far-left agitators
get the more that they create autonomous
zones and burn down stores and attack
people on the streets and all of these
things the average person is obviously
waking up to it and I can even tell you
this here in Los Angeles
I have friends who are far-left these I
mean far-left E Hollywood types who
publicly will you know tell you they're
Democrats and they're actually buying
guns for the first time I have several
friends like that so I think there is
actually the rubbers starting to meet
the road now it's like you can't just
have ideas anymore now we're going oh I
actually have to be able to protect
myself and and I think the fact that no
Democrat and obviously it can't be Joe
Biden is is willing to stand up against
this it's gonna basically burn down the
whole party and I sort of think that
that was the progressive plan the entire
time it was either we get Bernie in and
if we don't we just unleash this thing
and that's where we're at but I suspect
that Trump knows how to deal with this
and we should also add by the way that
you know if the if they don't if the
anti-shah people and the anarchists and
whatever don't show up to the rally that
is gonna be a peaceful rally tomorrow
because that's what the Trump rallies
are if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlists all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell